Many of you are probably already
familiar with the idea of MOOCs.
MOOCs stand for
Massive Open Online Course.
MOOCs are courses that are delivered
to the masses without scaling up our
teaching resources to match
the number of students who register.
Doesn't matter if 100
students register or 100,000.
We still have the same initial
resource allocation for that course.
A lot of companies nowadays
are producing MOOCs.
Coursera is producing MOOCs.
edX is producing MOOCs.
Udacity actually got
started producing MOOCs,
although has since has pivoted away
on a more credentialed approach.
There are a lot of interesting
constraints that we wrestle with when
producing MOOCs.
For one thing,
many of them are available for free.
And when it's available for free,
we need to minimize our
initial resource investment.
So that means we really need to be very
clever about how we design our MOOCs.
We need to be clever about how we design
our video material, so that we're not
expending a whole lot of money to
produce really excellent lectures or
anything like that.
We need to be clever about how
we design our assessments.
Assessments in MOOCs can
often be kind of trivial,
if they're just based on some
little multiple choice questions.
How do we design good assessments that
don't require us to hire an army of TAs,
or an army of graders to
evaluate all those assessments?
These are all very interesting issues
that we face when developing good,
massive open online courses.
And then really what we're
going to focus on in this lesson.
How do we develop good video material,
good assessments, good grading,
good things like that without
investing just a lot of money into
reaching all these students?